I just ordered six different burgers
five of them being vegetarian one of
them being beef will I taste a
difference which one will I like better
our vegetarian burgers actually healthy
[Music]
I'm coming fresh off my 30-day vegan
challenge I hope you enjoyed watching it
last week during my 30 day vegan trial I
actually ate some vegan burgers and
since they're all the rage I decided to
put them to the test
I want to focus on three things here
looking at all the nutrition facts first
calories impossible burger rings in as
the most calorie dense 710 calories when
compared to 6:30 for the Beyond burger
650 for a regular burger and the lowest
being the quinoa at 510 calories next I
want to jump to the sodium content I
didn't expect this but the meatless
burgers actually have really high sodium
content more than the actual beef burger
the beef burger has 780 milligrams of
sodium
but the beyond Patty has 950 and the
impossible has 12:10 even the quinoa has
730 it's clear that these meatless
burgers are trying to up the flavor by
putting more salt in there which can be
problematic for those who have high
blood pressure or heart disease that can
put a lot of strain on the heart and the
final macronutrient I want to focus on
is protein I would think the beef burger
would have the highest amount of protein
but that's not true impossible burger 47
grams of protein compared to the beef 39
grams compared to the beyond burger 33
grams and then the rest of these the
black bean sweet potato and quinoa in
the low 20s why is that important well
first of all you need protein to sustain
muscle especially for myself because you
know I'm trying to be a muscular person
but also because you need protein to
feel satiated meaning to feel full
having the impossible burger have 47
grams of protein will mean that you'll
eat it and probably feel very full as
opposed to sweet potato burger only 20
grams of protein you still may be hungry
after eating that one I'm ready to try
these burgers I want to know what they
feel like on my tongue what they smell
like what they taste like
and for you to get my rating
it's time to blindfold myself with a tie
ray what Christian whoo-hoo I'm ready
for my first burger I didn't see the
stack
why is everyone denying the fact that
I'm an honest human being I'm gonna talk
about three things on each of these
burgers one is the scent the mouthfeel
as I like to call it the mouth eNOS and
then taste and then I'll give it a out
of five stars I guess I feel like that's
reasonable oh that warm brioche bun all
of them have the same ingredients by the
way scent wise I already smell
vegetables it almost smells like a sweet
potato but I don't want to judge it just
yet all right oh no I know which one
that says this is the bean one for sure
this is never that trick on you wanted
to say it they're eating meat probably
booster loves that has thing in my teeth
mal dienes I would say I could mouth and
feel the bean which is kind of weird it
doesn't taste like a regular burger the
fact that it has standard ingredients
like lettuce and tomato and cheese makes
it taste better but it has a little bit
of sweetness to it then that taste right
away you get the bean thing hitting you
right in the face like you're eating a
Chipotle burrito or something I'll
probably give this two out of five
sorry bean burger next time to hydrate
okay this one smells decent oh my god
this could be this could be this could
be beef it smells really good I really
feel like this is beef let's give it a
taste
[Music]
see I think this one's trying to be beef
really hard I'm still getting a little
vegetable eat kick this is really good
there's something about it that I'm not
buying that it's me
there's just something there's like a
little mouthfeel was really good really
good tastes like beef it falls apart
like beef
it could be beef but I don't think so
I'm gonna go ahead and guess this is
impossible burger this one gets 3 out of
5 stars for me next cleansing the palate
why am i yelling alright
burger numero tres oh this one's heavy
oh yeah this feels this is a beef patty
if I'm getting tricked on this it's a
really embarrassing but it smells like a
fresh burger yeah this is a beef burger
my protein sensors on my tongue light it
up
if it's not I swear guys crazy dad
tastes like beef it smells like beef the
consistency is like beef it's not a
great burger
I'll give it like a 4 out of 5 next but
that was the burger right no are you not
gonna tell me all right burger Oh numero
Quatro oh my god this tastes like it I
mean it smells like pure vegetable God
now I'm confused is it a vegetable
burger I don't know what this woman is
doing
I don't fine I don't ask for sauce on
any of these and this one has sauce so
it's confusing I have no idea what do we
have left beyond quinoa this might be
the beyond burger
it smells like kind of like me I think
it's a beyond burger
I think the consistency is pretty
consistent with meat I want to just
take a bunch of the patty it's really
close to be it's like beef but a little
bit sweeter
I'll give it 3 out of 5 stars alright
numero Cinco solid weight has no real
scent I'm Ken with the sauce Oh what is
that
is this the beyond or impossible burner
that's good oh my god just might be the
beyond burger this is definitely out
meat if it's meat I'm sewn back I messed
up one of the other ones this is either
impossible or beyond
why just quinoa Oh God the taste is
weird it's a weird taste I don't like
this taste
I'll give it two stars I don't know what
that is we're gonna mark the fifth one
as a question my family next like really
good and tricking me with the mouthfeel
save the best for last
whoo this one's got some weight to it
okay this is definitely one of the
vegetarian ones I'm getting a little
nauseous this is a quinoa burger I just
got like a huge hit of quinoa or no
sorry sweet potato mouth feel really bad
it tastes like you're eating a sweet
burger it's not good one star yeah okay
here's my list let's see how I did here
burger number one was a black bean
burger I gave it two stars and I said it
was black beans which is correct the
second one was a quinoa Patty I said
beef I really said it was beef no I did
it I gave her three stars while the
quinoa patties coming in here and
surprising me third was the beef patty I
knew that I gave it four stars for was
the beyond burger and I got the beyond
burger
what's up five was impossible and I said
questionable beyond impossible or quinoa
I couldn't get that one and then the
sweet potato I said it was sweet potato
and I gave it one stock I did a really
good I got five out of six come on
that's impressive you guys got to give
me some love for getting five out of six
I think the biggest shocker out of all
of this is I said quinoa
patty was questionably beef I gave it
three stars that I thought it was an
simple burger I'm surprised the
impossible burger kind of let me down
let's talk nutrition and health when it
comes to these meatless burgers first
and it's the thing that surprised me the
most on the burgers that tasted very
close to meat they actually had macros
that were quite similar if not worse
than the actual beef burger
for example the impossible burger has
more saturated fat more calories more
sodium than a traditional beef burger I
can't really go ahead and call these
health foods because there's still
indulgences we should treat them the
same way as we do regular burgers that
you should have them only occasionally
only as a treat because if we fall into
the category of thinking these are held
foods people gonna start eating them as
part of their regular diets and that's
not healthy I noticed a pattern the
closer they taste to meat the more
likely they are to be unhealthy in terms
of their macros when I say I'm healthy I
mean high amounts of saturated fats high
in calories high in sodium because if
you look at the sweet potato the quinoa
the black bean those are generally lower
in sodium lower and fats in comparison
to the impossible and Beyond burger
which tastes very very similar to the
actual beef burger I think the biggest
positive of this meatless burgers is
that we can decrease overall meat
consumption that's a good thing not only
for your health but for the environment
as well I'm a big fan of meatless
Mondays no one's saying you have to go
vegan in order to be healthy you can
decrease your meat consumption have a
plant focus diet and still be incredibly
healthy if not healthier than if you
were following a traditional vegan diet
I actually said that in my vegan video
this is becoming a mega business and I'm
gonna keep a close eye on this just to
make sure that we still had in the right
direction and we don't start throwing a
bunch of preservatives and processed
ingredients into these meatless burgers
because if something wrong is to change
I want to be the first to let you guys
know click here for my 30-day vegan
challenge video so you can see how I
suffered where I improved and what I
learned about myself as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]